8 jeunes sur 10 souhaitent rentrer au
pays une fois leurs études terminées
dans la grande majorité
tous veulent se rapprocher de leurs
familles et participer au développement
économique de l'île
mais presque tous craignent de ne pas
trouver un poste ou encore un salaire
correspondant à leur niveau et c'est
sans doute cette peur générale qui
freine le retour du plus grand nombre
c'est vrai qu'il ya des parcours qui
sont difficiles bien des personnes qui
reviennent qui ont des difficultés qui
parfois sans contrainte et à repartir et
on en connaît tous mais c'est une
minorité
donc il faut régler il faut écouter ces
personnes il faut régler leurs problèmes
mais il faut aussi mettre davantage en
valeur la majorité des parcours c'est à
dire les parcours qui se passe bien on
le sait l'insertion martin l'insertion
professionnelle des martiniquais qu'une
des diplômés qui ont une expérience à
l'extérieur est bien meilleure que celle
des hommes
c'est la sénatrice catherine conconne
qui a initié le programme allait virer
elle souhaite trouver un moyen de
limiter le déclin démographique qui
semble s'accélérer moins de 10 ans la
martinique a perdu plus de 35000
habitants
nous sommes passés de 400 mo a
aujourd'hui moins de 370 milles et le
phénomène est en nette accélération
alors qu'est ce qu'on veut dans un pays
qui dans 20 ans ne noie plus de deux
martiniquais ou allod martin qui est
très âgé
tous les jeunes sont repartis tous les
éléments du développement économique
sont si prompts le le développement
culturel s'écroule toutes les
infrastructures ont été construites vous
être surdimensionnés par rapport à la
population
je crois que personne ne veut de ça ce
questionnaire numérique n'est que la
première étape du programme allait virer
catherine conconne prévoit 20 mesures
d'accompagnement mais également le
renforcement de la formation en
martinique